la tavola ouija è una famosissima tavola
che serve per evocare gli spiriti
occorrente la tavola ouija che questa
qua la lente della tavola ouija che va
posizionata sopra la tavola ci si mette
su un tavolo con le luci spente in
silenzio con gli amici e tutti quanti
temono mettere il dito sulla lente della
tavola se lo spirito è presente la lente
si muoverà sulle lettere cercando di
formare le parole o delle sentenze ho
deciso di farci un prank ho attaccato
sul retro della lente della tavola
questo tappo che contiene una calamita
il tappo dello stesso colore della lente
quindi si confonde benissimo col pezzo
dopo l'ikea ragazzi o delle altre
calamite attaccate ad un calzino che
metterò sotto il ginocchio in modo tale
da poter controllare la lente sulla
tavola in questo modo vabbè avete capito
quindi io seduto comodamente davanti a
un tavolo con la tavola ouija davanti mi
basterà mettere in ginocchio sotto il
tavolo per poter muovere la lente che
sta sulla tavola ouija e far credere a
tutti quelli che sono intorno che la
lente si stia muovendo la sola perché
non ci sono fili non c'è niente a
nessuno viene in mente che è una
calamità in realtà muoverle ho deciso di
fare questo scherzo ad un mio amico che
fa lo youtuber si chiama marco marco
merino e di questo frank mi hanno
aiutato altri due amici che sono il
fratello di marco è una ragazza che
aveva già fatto altre sedute e quindi
sapeva come manovrare il tutto e
renderlo più realistico l'unicorno alla
conoscenza di questa cosa era marco gli
altri erano a conoscenza del brand che
stavo per fare quindi tutti sapevano
tranne marco rilascio al plank buona
visione
dovete fare tipo delle ict qualcosa
perché facciamo abbastà tutti tranquilli
o semplicemente si sta un attimo di
silenzio inizio mettiamo sulle dita
vediamo che ci siamo come l'amianto
malissimo
allora polsi sollevati non dovete
toccarvi fra di voi non dovete toccare
le mani fra di loro non solo dito non
appoggiate né troppo né troppo cosi un
uomo ok simo perfetto farlo sensi è un
anno libera che mi vien da ridere perché
non ispirano le spese da hughes e louis
dai dai dai
c'è una dele
mentre i ragazzi stavano parlando
accidentalmente con il mio ginocchio ho
fatto muovere la lente della tavola
ouija marco purtroppo se n'è accorto e
quindi da lì è iniziato a dare i primi
segni di panico può farti una domanda se
di vajassa sì se dice no no questo sì
l'ho visto che cosa africana sono io non
ne vedo se voglio faccio le domande di
introduzione ci siamo
se qualcuno vuole parlare con noi noi
siamo qua
non vuole parlarci attraverso questa
modalità problema risulta chiusa che
vuoi tornare watching
cosi luciano emmer è successo
magari non riesce a incanalarsi forno
cluster l'azienda non fatemi in corea
non c'è nessuno
e secondo voi la reazione di marco a
tutto questo vale potrà mai essere stata
alcuna
ma può fare per lo scudetto marco no no
dai ragazzi o scherzare c'è una cosa in
due
stavo scherzando ma marco non far
vincere con almeno dell'associazione
marco ex suocero piccazzo di noi a non
aveva beh no no io vorrei chiuderla io
voglio chiuderla lì voglio lui e le
guardo abbiamo fatto una cagata
[Musica]
tranquilli io vorrei contrarsi
io l'ho ripresa questa volta sì io l'ho
veramente ripreso testa ma ci sono dei
video su internet di cose così sentiamo
chiude un oscuro spy non farà veramente
parole c'è duro di tutti stai male 3
nella mia vita ma tu sei così tranquillo
perché spiegherebbe così scandalosa
spiegherebbe troppo se qualcuno vuole
parlare con noi noi siamo poi vorremmo
ascoltare specialmente uno di noi
aspettami a scegliere un ottimo
però comunque va sempre sullo quindi
probabilmente ragazzi va bene così allo
scherzo si dice che andrebbe veramente
funzionato ed io ne ha fatte altre ci è
successo a questa cosa si muova da solo
che simona da sola non così possibile
non è possibile non è possibile non è
possibile stavolta non ci voglio che non
è possibile
ok che cosa dura però a me interessa
troppo non per curiosità ma dal fatto i
miei mi piacerebbe fare un'ultima
domanda e poi chiudere una tranquilla va
bene ne ho fatte io no ma devo farlo
riprendere non hanno avuto anch'io ho
mai neppure nel mai successo e visive
però calma non possiamo ancora quelli di
prima se c'è qualcuno intanto ci scusi
se prima con le domande siamo stati
troppo veloci devi sapere che molte di
questa stanza non aveva un abitudine
quindi perdono
innanzitutto le parte va bene noi tutti
siamo pronti
l ultima domanda prima di salutarti poi
risponderò ancora vuoi parlare con marco
hawk ride
non possa che la agosto
si passa alla carica sul basta allora se
volete sciogliere così si può far
parlarne anche alla luce decidete voi
cosa fai
essendo che siamo riusciti ad andare su
cuba va bene così poter accendere to
stata qui chiude la questione rom
marco da batteria
ecco se questa cosa qua dovesse mai
andare in giro che nina fiat dove per me
commentare questa cosa spiega poi solo
qualcosa almeno questo è assolutamente
abbiamo provato a fare la propria volta
all'esperimento usa per me per lorenzo
nella prima volta risposte ambigue ma
qualcosa è successo abbiamo documentato
ha documentato quindi una volta finita
la seduta marco non riesce a spiegarsi
che cos'è successo e quindi chiama un
suo amico per raccontargli tutte per
sfogarsi con qualcuno che non era
presente
dico normale e il dubbio cosa scegli il
pacchetto era questo si smorzano sola
cadetto uscite saluta marco sei tu che
mi the camera
guarda la faccia della disperazione
guarda che la ripresa
l'hai presa nel sacco bene che ha
scoperto terriccio tutto sindaco
giampieri partire per niente il polo io
l'avevo già detto che dobbiamo farlo
scherza cicciotto lui il gene calcare
per poi sa fare il manicomio man
benissimo sto male ti devo spiegare come
ho fatto questa cosa ma è la calamita
che sta sul mio ginocchio manches e le
tre crea tenere cucita ma funziona che
tu metti la cosa qua e poi attacchi in
ginocchio sotto una più che al tavolo è
più che altro tour chase è riuscito a
muoverti senza far capire comunali tutto
questo metodo finisce finisce sulla
signora che si chiama dailymotion che è
un sito nuovo di video bene fa ha tutti
i contatti che ho adesso si regia fatti
uno scherzo la revoca mian demo inoltre
io ho detto pure aclista è quindi
ragazzi questo era il break fatto a
marco ringrazio tutti i partecipanti a
questo video lascio anche il canale di
marco e ciccio che il parco giochi
prossimamente denominato the parco
ginocchio spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi non ho avuto la
reazione quella che speravo cioè quella
che eri uno che si è cagato addosso ho
avuto una zona ancora migliore di quello
che ha voluto continuare se minchia
complimenti o arco
io mi sarei lanciato dalla finestra ai
ragazzi concludono episodio spero che
visto vi sia piaciuto che speriamo che
non lo vedono tutti questo video perché
prossimamente farò questo frank anche
alle altre persone quindi ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto cose se vi piace al
momento è un mi piace anche i vari
social che come il totale a descrizione
sensori siti statici vediamolo costruito
bella ragazzi